today's guest is uh hilarious uh she
makes me laugh she makes me feel good
you know she's an uplifting gal and um
and i'm just really just i mean i'm just
tickled
i am just tickled to have her it is
comedian chelsea lynne
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
can you imagine a skull it between your
legs i cannot and very few women get to
know what that's like and i do
um well
air conditioning it's hot i'm sweating
are you yeah
well i'm large thank you yeah so i have
an extra layer
anyway so i get hot but yeah it's hot in
here is your
i know i've seen some of your family
members that are more kind of a
rubenesque vibe do you feel
do you is your family just kind of a
bigger family
no no not at all um
i've got two sisters and an aunt and
cousins and that's really about it
everybody else is dead really yeah
or just don't have relationships with
them yeah you know
yeah yeah yeah and one or the other dang
yeah
um no my air conditioner went out
yesterday
so there's no air in here oh there's air
i
i just turned it uh off made it colder
oh you did
just now it'll be good we'll just sweat
the whole time
yeah no there's no but there's no rules
to this theo lost it in his apartment
oh and it's been hotter than
yeah this is like texas heat yeah we're
not used to this out here
well it's bad and i just didn't know
what to do so i got one of those floor
fans and i put all took all the ice out
of the freezer and put it right on the
floor
in front of it did it work like on a
cookie sheet did it work
that's supposed to work i think it did
something
but you're used to luxury i'm you know
what you're so hungry but i'm used to
freaking having
air conditioning yeah which is luxury
and look it
you know what you really i'll tell you
this the second went an hour after
it went out i was googling like native
american [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying i'm starting to
see yeah texting my mom i'm like aren't
we part cherokee or whatever i can't
even
handle you know just the lack of just
yeah man just the comfort for real and
damn
i just feel bad uh greg my husband
[ __ ] about the
uh electric bill cause i run the air 24
7. yeah i keep it like 68 he freaks the
[ __ ] out yeah okay
my stepmom does that she's on pills
though oh yeah that makes sense
yeah if you're on pills dude yeah
i can't even dude nothing goes with a
percocet like a little bit air
conditioner
yeah that makes sense for sure but i'm
sorry i interrupted you go on oh i don't
know what i was talking about
but he so he you have the air
conditioner going oh
so that's what i s that's what i spend
my money on yeah
is air conditioning yeah yeah definitely
i'm dead serious
comfort last summer one of our bills was
like 1200
for the yeah and i was like he threw a i
was like i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i'm comfortable yeah that's all
that matters
we're doing it yeah oh yeah yeah if this
is living large it's just living large
exactly i like that yeah and you guys
live
in um san diego
san diego yeah because i saw you down
there at the comedy store yeah
that's the first time yeah i ever knew
about you so here's what happened here's
how i discovered you
okay so i was like man i want to go see
some comedy i was like let's let's uh
take a look
you know i looked up the comedy store
was going going through the schedule
didn't really see anybody that i knew
saw a picture of you and go oh he's cute
as [ __ ]
let me youtube see see if you know i'm
gonna go see him
first video i was like i'm buying
[ __ ] tickets oh that's sorry follow
on um instagram you had like
17 000 followers maybe dang yeah
started following you almost a damn
shelter
went and saw you you were so [ __ ]
funny and afterwards were so
[ __ ] nice to me and my sisters i was
like forever
fan forever forever [ __ ] fan man
that's sweet
and then yeah and then you blew up and
now i'm on your podcast i'm freaking out
i know it's so
for having me no i'm so happy to have
you and i'm glad
i mean i think we really lucked out even
by having you on this week because i
feel like you're kind of having like a
moment
a little bit is that crazy to say that i
know that sounds really no
that's really for a lot of people it's
kind of coming out of the closet or
whatever but this is like a
like uh yeah like i saw you on michael
bisping's damn instagram and i'm just
like
how are all these worlds colliding damn
british
i went viral a couple days ago you know
he's a one-eyed british man dude i don't
know
it's just i'm just wrong i'm just
rolling with it yeah day to day
i have no idea what's happening i'm just
like all right let's do this
uh but you just hit a million on
instagram yeah
you know what instagram it's different
so i have a million on every on youtube
i know yeah sorry
everywhere else i have a million i just
started tick tock and got a million on
tick tock
in like two months and i've posted like
four videos and i'm just kind of like
okay million whatever i don't really
care
something about instagram man i'm like i
hit a million on instagram
i think it's harder to grow on instagram
people are
stingy with that follow button yeah
people are a little stingy yeah
i think especially right like now i feel
like
people have been um you know i feel like
there's
it's instagram's been a while around for
a while now yeah so it's not you know
people aren't just as like oh yeah i'm
get you know
i'm in i'm following anybody you know
i'll follow any
you know the time i follow anybody with
a damn tit yeah
yeah i follow anybody that's not in a
damn wheelchair you know what i'm saying
my requirements were very slim at a
certain point right yeah but now it's a
little bit more
you know yep exactly um but that had to
feel good when did that happen when did
you hit
two days ago wow two days ago and what
were y'all doing where were you i mean
this is your damn freaking electronic
jfk right here
oh gosh just sitting on my couch in a
moo moo
just watching dateline oh and i was like
oh i had a friend text me
and he was like oh congratulations on me
i'm like oh i knew what happened that
day
but i was like oh i get on they're like
hey look at that
and that was pretty much it everybody's
like how you gonna celebrate and like
celebrate
like you know how people get balloons
and [ __ ] yeah i made fun of it a while
back and my sister was going to get me
balloons just to [ __ ] with me and i was
like you i'll pop them
do not [ __ ] get me congratulation
balloons
holy [ __ ] that's embarrassing do not
i'll pop them dude there almost is
look i think if you're getting
congratulation balloons
you aren't doing enough with your life
i'm gonna go out on a damn limb and say
that
oh because anytime somebody needs to get
you damn
balloons to show that you have some kind
of damage
[ __ ] that's fine sometimes it's just god
i don't know
you see some [ __ ] walk over with a
pack of balloons in a damn
you know and then my aunt one time like
they have the little thing that's filled
with a uh
it has a balloon another balloon that's
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's filled
with something
confetti or yeah yeah candy yeah yeah
she would open that
and it's saying nobody was just saying
you know what i'm saying it was just
like saying
and she if you're buying a balloon in a
balloon yeah you got money
you got money that's not a regular
balloon you know yeah you definitely got
money there
but yeah that had to be so wild but
that's when i was just like
holy smokes like this is so crazy and
it's so awesome that everybody starts to
know about you
yeah you know yeah it's super weird
because
you're so funny uh and
do you feel like like you're funny comes
from where like
because you weren't a stand-up to start
with no
no um so how did yeah let's do your
origin story damn it
yeah where do you want to start clark
kent start in the damn mail room
so you know i don't know where the funny
comes from i think i had such a
um i guess a shitty childhood
that i kind of had to you know i was the
poor kid in school i was the large kid
in school you know so i had to have
something yeah so i think that just like
came out of me probably early junior
high
were you funny then yeah i think so oh i
wish we had those videos
yeah yeah i know i was saying about that
i was like man i wish we had i wish i
could vlog back then
oh my god to see that [ __ ] but um
so funny where were you funny at like
was there like an environment that you
were kind of really shined in you know
was it
a particular place or a certain group
i've
always remembered this and this may be
cheesy as hell but i remember the first
time
i made a room laugh and i was in
seventh grade um basketball practice
and we after practice sex symbol
basketball yeah oh yeah
wow yeah and uh um
went back to the uh locker room
everybody's getting ready for class
forever i don't even know what was said
i have no clue
but i had been to this school about a
month so i didn't really know
you know and um i don't know what i said
but the whole [ __ ] locker room was
piss in their pants and somebody goes
she's funny and that always just stuck
with me i'm like oh
you know kind of so that was like the
first time i remember like you know
wow yeah um yeah there's something
when you're saying that it makes me it
takes me back to those times yeah like
there's something magical when you don't
feel like you have
something that people that people see
you know and then when they say that
you're funny you're like
oh yeah oh yeah it's almost like thank
god there's some i have some way
yeah for people to see me you know do
you ever say something do you ever say
something and then somebody dies
laughing and you didn't think it was
funny
but they thought it was the funniest
thing they've ever heard in their life
that happens to me all the time i'm like
i was i am not that funny and they're
like
dying well i think you start to become
well some people start to become kind of
there's times where i know i'm doing
something funny and people don't know it
yet
um that's always kind of fun when like
and that's
it's not that i'm doing it on purpose
it's just i know my brain starts to see
a pattern of like oh
this is where they're at and this is
where my brain is over here right now
and so
in a second this is all you know this
corner is gonna turn or something
yeah um sometimes though people like
stuff
like i'm one i watch when i watch your
videos i notice a lot there's a little
things that i like
like when your cousin jim when that
little fella just turns his head at a
certain angle
and i just see the cut of that boy just
damn
where his neck just runs right into his
damn forehead you know i just
i found that guy on instagram god flew
him out to do a vid i said you gotta
come do a video with me love that
just to look and then i love him and so
i think there's one thing that that
really for me about you
is that you're s the people you find
funny i find so funny
that it's like oh wow i can trust her on
different levels not only to
entertain me but also like uh
she sees like something that that
a lot of people maybe wouldn't see yeah
you know i mean some people see this
fella a little gem and they might even
you know somebody probably damn them you
know you get a couple of them you know
we've got to do those ball players yeah
yeah yeah for sure
and they'll play down full back in a
[ __ ] haunted house with this dude you
know
but um but yeah i think that's one
that's one of the things i notice as i
see more your stuff that makes me laugh
more i think is like trusting that
you're going to lead me also to
something funny you know
oh thank you and just the cuteness of it
like the damn
ant and just the there's a whole
storyline to it
and it's all made up on the spot man and
i just roll with it i try to remember
the storyline for future [ __ ]
it's just it's just all [ __ ] crazy
it's so funny yeah it's just such a good
you do you do such a great job i think
of just bringing joy especially during
like the coronavirus time i feel like
i've had such a tough time during all
this
of trying to like figure out what's
funny or be
like just be in the funny yeah um
do you feel like it's been tougher
during this time or do you feel like
opposite
opposite for me i feel like my well my
shit's been thriving since
you know um my creative's been thriving
my just everything for some reason just
the total opposite for me yeah i was
supposed to go
on tour oh yeah we're gonna and you
i don't know if you remember but like
two or three years ago we did um
josh wolfe joshua wilson do you remember
me telling you i was like man i don't
know
i don't know if i wanted to stand up i'm
kind of scared and you were like why
and i was like i don't know and you're
like just do it and i literally was like
i left i was like
yeah he's right and so i've literally
started stand up because of that oh wow
yeah isn't that crazy yeah i can't
believe it you were like
huh no just do it and i was like he's
[ __ ] right
well i think some people it's like you
wanna you just want to listen to the
person you you want to be a part of
their world
you know they're bringing the joy you
know sometimes the people are selling
jokes sometimes people are selling
joy not really selling it but you know i
just feel like people want to be in your
world
yeah you know and once you create like a
world people want to be in it yeah so
that's great then so you were playing on
tour that's the thing i was going to ask
you so
so with starting out you started out
where at like just being funny where'd
you grow up at
uh thackerville oklahoma okay it's about
a
45 minutes north of dallas it's right on
the oklahoma texas border okay i
graduated high school with 12 people
oh damn yeah 12 people we did not have a
football team we did not have band we
did not have
art like nothing did y'all have like a
like a youth group or something or
religious
oh yeah we had this thing called the
upper room and my
best friend's family ran it damn yeah
and that was that was all there was to
do play play softball and go to the
upper room and they just have like
pool tables and and christian rock
you know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah yeah dude and that was it
that was that was all i did that was fun
that was a social life oh yeah
and is thackerville a big place or no oh
no we've got
um oh when i was there we didn't even
have a stoplight
now there's a stoplight because we have
the world's largest casino
yeah so it's random we have nothing but
dirt
roads uh one convenience store that's it
and then the world's largest casino
yeah well that's enough really i mean
it's a that's the thing you know that's
all you need
yeah you would think that's all you need
people want more
yeah yeah people and some people need
more man
yeah um that's true so dackerville so
you graduated from there and then you
went
because i was kind of it was kind of
surprising when i saw you in san diego
because i'm like
this doesn't seem to fit everything but
everything works
yeah but it was surprising to me so no
well to me too
so i graduated college married greg
okay we moved to dallas so we were there
for like three years
um he's looking for he was looking for a
new job oh god
i was working at whole foods at the time
dude
in the bakery come home from work and
he's like oh i've got a job interview
i'm like that's great we're at and he
was like it's this job in san diego and
i was literally like i thought he was
[ __ ] with me i'm like why did you
apply for a job in san diego
and he's like i didn't a recruiter
reached out and i'm like
we're not moving to san diego that's
called the military craig
for real he's like yeah it's just it's a
unique group you know that
they've been in business for a couple
hundred years they've reached out to me
yeah um there's battleship opportunities
so we moved to san diego it's supposed
to be temporary wow and once i got out
once we got out here i was like
i don't want to live anywhere else
really yeah
yeah and then that's when [ __ ] started
to pop for me
because that's a big move i mean moving
from a place where you have
the comfort and you guys especially
going from like into dallas that's a big
move to go out west oh it was huge
and and then you get the shock of
everything being more expensive out here
which is so true i think i think our one
bedroom apartment was like 700 a month
we come out here and it's like 2 200
you know i mean we were like um yeah it
was a big shock we're used to it now
um when we when we moved to san diego i
had just started the social media stuff
so i
didn't really have a lot of followers
and then it just slowly we've been
we've been in san diego seven years
almost eight maybe
yeah yeah it's flown by yeah yeah
and uh and so with the social media so
you do the characters kind of but a lot
of it all you always run into all of it
it's always seems like a mix of you and
the characters and just like a
kind of a world kind of do you ever get
like scared to try something new
are there things that you get afraid to
try oh yeah
and not for me but because people get
pissed you know what i mean
so i've years ago i tried to do a couple
other characters besides trailer trash
tammy and people let's go to this we'll
go to this video right here just i don't
mean to interrupt you no you're good but
this
you know we're trying to have nick keep
his job and so this is where he
interjects good videos
i'm a big fan of you and all your videos
i watch them every day
also your mum bangs my question is for
you
are you scared to see something really
outrageous or so outrageous that
people might take offense to it and you
might get
what we call cancel culture let me know
bye oh my god she's cute
um i'm not like in terms of comedy not
afraid to say anything
like i'll joke about whatever um so
in that way i'm not i guess i'm not
scared to to
but the cancel culture thing holy [ __ ]
yeah you gotta i mean you you gotta
watch like it's ridiculous
i feel like you yeah that that's on
that's definitely always in the back of
my mind
is it yours i mean all my i didn't know
all my friends were damn sex offenders
you know until
you know holy [ __ ] until hollywood told
me that they were
you know surprised me with that
i think it here's when it gets scary for
me so like i have a
netflix special that we're gonna do
sometime in
when the world opens back up so we have
like a deal over there and
trying to work on a cartoon right now
and um
so i get scared of i know that those are
the things that are at risk for me
yeah so it's like i can you know i can
say whatever i want to say
but i have to since those things are on
the other side of the teeter-totter
yeah if it were just my podcast and just
uh social medias then
i wouldn't i think i wouldn't there
wouldn't be anything on that other side
of the teeter-totter to lose
yeah but right now those are things
where an article or something
and then people get scared
and in the podcasting world it's like
you know some of the guys that something
happens and then
people are like why don't they still do
their podcast
and well because the advertisers say we
don't want to be on this podcast right
now and so then
you know they just get they get really
nervous i guess as well you know but um
right anyway so yeah where does it where
does it hit with you
oh gosh for me so anything
political i don't mess with yeah for
multiple reasons not really because i'm
scared of the cancel culture thing
but for me it's like you know i yeah i
have a large platform and i've and
very rarely will people message me and
say you need to use your platform for
this or that
99.9 of people message me and say thank
you
for not thank you for being a place
where i can go and get away from that
and laugh so that's the number one
reason
i love it why i i really you know try to
stick with
just comedy nothing too you know crazy
political and
and it's not that i'm afraid of like the
backlash or whatever
it's just you know literally dolly
parton is my
you know and i'm just following her
footsteps she
really keeps it like you know i'm just
here to bring entertainment
bring laughs bring smiles i'm not here
to you can go to another page for that
[ __ ] yeah
you know here we're talking about
titties yeah saggy titties you know what
i mean like that's all i'm hearing
bags baby exactly amen yeah something to
hold a set of balloons down you know
there you go you need a big titties
something
to hold down a set of damn get well
balloons
you get these small titties dude you'll
never get well no
exactly dude i remember my mother had
the smallest breast god forbid and i
love her and she listens to this podcast
which
almost breaks my heart a lot of times
but um and makes my heart
at the same time oh but damn she had
them small
i mean you had to beat a little milk out
of it damn
that's why i think i still got that
nervous energy you know you see a baby
trying to just
breastfeed off a small titty there's
nothing yeah
got to break your heart yeah you see a
baby
you got to work hard for that meal oh
you can't even shake a small tit
yeah but i'm hurting somebody's back
without hurting somebody's back
it's just a different place man for sure
a different place so
sure but yeah you want one thing so then
then i start to feel like this
i start to feel like well as comedians
you're also supposed to
and this may be where maybe the line
gets a little different for
um me coming from a background more of
stand-up comedy
is that you're supposed to be able to
comment on things you're supposed to be
able to
at least to be able to take a swing at
things without
um you know without being judged just
for taking a swing
yeah and so that's where it gets tricky
for me sometimes a stand-up because it's
like
you want to be able to kind of speak out
or push the boundaries or
and then it really starts to feel
real real limiting when your voice
starts to get limited you know
but but then maybe i'm like i just need
to start to be more creative i start to
you know i'm finally starting to land in
that place instead of the place of
oh this you know ah you know the yeah
the frustration
for see for stand up comedy i feel like
it's
i feel like that's fine for sure to push
that [ __ ]
i'm worried about like oh an old tweet
or
if i say something in a vlog i really
have and not that i go around saying
[ __ ] that would get me canceled anyway i
don't right i really don't but you you
have to like yeah you have to like watch
that [ __ ] if you're
if you're doing stuff not only on the
stage does that make sense like oh
totally you know like you if you put
yourself out there everywhere stage
youtube vlogging snapchat like i mean
it just grows bigger the possibility
yeah yeah the possibility of more people
getting offended as well
yeah well it says i mean what if 10
years from now it's they have semen
lives matter you know
and anybody that ever swallowed after a
[ __ ] is going to jail you know what
i'm saying it starts to make me think
because we just don't know what the line
is going to be in the future
i know did you see my instagram store
yesterday i don't know if you did
i uh i had a lady come to the house to
give me a massage that i found on the
internet oh god
she was a crackhead okay and so i made a
whole instagram story
making fun of her and telling them what
happened she passed out during my
massage but it's a whole thing
and when you know people don't make fun
of it right now
yeah let's watch it and i literally said
i'm gonna make fun of whatever the [ __ ]
i want to make fun of
it's long but yeah yeah yeah i decided
to splurge and find someone to come to
the house and
give a massage look i've been on this
site and so is nick
to be honest back page yeah
rip back page as well and now you have
to do adult friend search
but thankfully i have blockers on my
phone now so i'm doing well
well that's not what i got let's see
what you got i got a [ __ ] crackhead
amen
photo was old she on crack now yes the
bait and switch i found that she got me
catfished me yeah she got me you
couldn't even hardly understand her when
she talked i'll see osbourne
oh man but then she said she comes in
and i'm immediately weirded out i almost
tell her i'll pay her for her time
but she's got a bounce i've done that
before as well dude
i've been so scared i went and dropped
the 300
off the balcony down to the woman holy
[ __ ] i'm kind of freaking
just some kind of bootleg mardi gras
oh so i'm like [ __ ] it let's just see
what happens there we go that's what i
like that entrepreneurial spirit
um then she tells me that she left her
phone and purse
in his car and she forgot to tell him
when to be back she
she her car broke down so somebody
dropped her off another crackhead
oh yeah she's got that muscular pimp if
she's out there getting massages
yeah as she can log into her facebook
somewhere and message him so you didn't
take any pictures of her though
no well see now then i think that that's
totally fine oh no oh yeah i didn't post
pic no no no you weren't blasting no
no no but the story is hilarious she she
fell asleep on me during my massage and
was still massaging me oh yeah
she passed out on me and was still
massaging me and that's crack baby
yeah that's crack i said i said are you
good and she and she
still laying on me goes yeah i want i
say because you're you're laying on me
yeah and she goes oh yeah these are new
clothes
something a crackhead would say they
used to call it crack structure dude so
they said people that would do crack and
they would come and uh
build like in our area they had a group
of young men that would do crack and
you'd see them out there zombied out but
still
building i saw a guy speak in a building
i saw a guy on crack one time at a uh
build-a-bear and he zoned out bro
zero eyes open you know zero out of two
eyes open and he's still in his bear and
he still made that better wow
damn that's funny and he still made that
bear dude got the bow right in the
middle
um he did it all even the little where
you put the one two three on the feet
yeah god he did it passed out the whole
time unconscious
completely unconscious dude like if you
put that dude right now in a court of
law with that
one hand on the bible or or even just a
berenstain bears book you know whatever
meant more to him
and you asked him hey bugaboo you know
did you ever build a bear
unconscious i bet he would lie about it
and he would lie unknowingly oh man oh
that's good [ __ ]
um so
what else we got some questions that
came in yeah and i'm not giving up on my
ability to conversate with you yet
oh you're good okay good hey i'm having
fun are you
yeah i'm so glad you're here this is so
oh thank you
uh yeah surprised people sent
questions in that's that's great yeah we
got a lot didn't we
yeah like 15. some are like kind of the
same old habit yeah we got a lot for you
okay
what's up tammy what's up theo quick
question what was your first experience
with tobacco was it that
cowboy killer or was it that smokeless
lip filler gang gang nicotine buzz oh
yeah
and a fella with a nice body there too
bro
tank top beautiful young fella right
there two arms
yeah where i'm from that's a damn
highlight two arms one eyebrow oh you
show up with two arms dog
yeah he's cute oh somebody's getting
married
yes [ __ ] bro you know uh i've
never smoked have you smoked
no no i mean i've tried it but i've
never like been a smoker
oh yeah i'm six months off of cigarettes
right okay okay
um my grandma and parent everyone around
me
growing up chained smokers no so i you
know as a little kid would like
try nah what did they smoke you what do
you remember what kind
well grandma had to get that jacket
mm-hmm
so marlboro
yeah yeah we were always decked out in
marlboro
everything head to toe that's how much
she smoked and you had to smoke like
twenty thousand dollars worth of
cigarettes to get a jacket yeah and we
had closets full
wow you know yeah those jackets yeah
those are some prized pieces
yeah you saw that it was the adults did
the marlboros and the children did
those kool-aid points that were on the
back of the little kool-aid packages
and we'd save up and get a pitcher every
year we'd have a family meeting
and we'd do what we wanted to do with
the points you know man
and you could get a little pitcher you
could get a little uh one year we spent
all
of them got my little sister a damn vest
dude nothing was a piece of [ __ ]
oh it was it wasn't nice i mean it was
you think a vest would be nice
you would think and damn
it was just i don't know it was almost
like a discontinued
uh um
life jacket you know that they were
marketing his clothing
no no they can't do that they can god
they got you
they got yeah they got you they got us
butt but yeah those marlboros and so
your family would just smoke them
oh yeah and what would you do just watch
them yeah
oh wow that was like we had no cable so
what else were we gonna do you know
let's watch grandma's cheeks turn you
turn you know
we had channels 10 and 12. we got tired
of soap operas so we just sat there and
watched them smoke
what soap operas were y'all watching oh
my gosh
um we used to watch like the days of our
life just all that [ __ ]
oh yeah literally that's all there was
guiding light as we got yep yeah we
watched them all
santa barbara that was an old one my
sister still watches them
i haven't watched them since high school
but she still watches them that's really
interesting dedicated
yeah that can really lead to loneliness
as well
yeah um here's a young lady right here
that has a question
[Music]
lauren virginia love you both if you
didn't like my last question
here's another question theo one time
you said that
you have like a nose power when you go
into a public bathroom you can tell if
someone just
took a dump or not um i think a lot of
people have that power
but what's worse than that is if you go
into the female bathroom
after a girl who's currently
um going through the time of the month
ugh that smell is worse than poop
chelsea since you're a girl and you can
attest to that
tell theo what's up plus you know
because apparently your sisters got a
little funky
love you both thank you so much for
being so funny and awesome
bye so yeah
um is that a real thing because i've
always had this superpower and it's uh
i mean i guess some people say it's not
a superpower but if i go into a bathroom
if someone has been doing poop in there
i can tell immediately when i walk oh i
can usually smell it in the hallway
oh my god really oh yeah god dude you
might be a damn
you might be from egypt or something
yeah
so the whole female thing it's it
it smells like you walked into a room
that has
a pile of a million pennies oh my god
like a bank like a little bad bank like
a little like the back of the bank that
holds all the coins
oh yeah it's like a it's like a copper
smell
mixed in with some funk oh yeah so so
y'all just have [ __ ]
we have [ __ ] and blood oh so it's very
very
very kind of like vietnam like yeah
kinda if you think about it damn
i never thought about that and so you
know you when you walk in there you know
if that's been going on
yeah well here's what here's the deal
like they'll well that's
that's why okay that's if she wore a pad
and it's soaked up in [ __ ] a gallon
of water
and then leaves it in the trash okay
relax
man at least drop it off at the fire
department
what is going on hey this is real life
you did not know about this i didn't
know about this
man yeah women are disgusting i knew
that but i didn't know
that people are just abandoning yeah
potential families
yeah okay on that little family pinata i
didn't know people are just
abandoning those things oh god that's
just
curbside in the damn bathroom
now
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm sorry y'all are going
through that i didn't know that
yeah that's why i'm quick to use the
men's bathroom
i'll i'll just use the men's bathroom
like i have no problem and the men's
bathroom is usually
empty and the women's is always full if
there's a line i'll go to the men's i
don't give a [ __ ]
well it's really you know it's really a
strong move when you say that because
nowadays if i see a woman in there i
leave i don't want to be
sex crying i don't want to be me too i
don't want to be
i'm just afraid of everything so it's
like it's yours now you know yeah but
i'll go out there and write a w-o on the
[ __ ] door no if it's like a big
men's bathroom with like urinals and
stalls and there's other like i won't
like but if it's like a single
you know what i'm talking about like a
gas station bathroom with one and
there's one
you know and the women's is full i'll go
the men's but i won't walk in there and
walk up beside a urinal and you know
take
no no no but you know what i'm talking
about if it's like a single i'll use the
men's i don't give a [ __ ] wow
yeah i like that yeah and do you uh have
you guys ever been to the bathrooms at
the dallas cowboys stadium or not i've
never been
how are they i've never been your
husband's here and he didn't take you
there no he hates the cowboys
oh damn but at least take her to the
damn place that's true that's true you
know what i'm saying dude
i [ __ ] hate a claim jumper but i've
been to that [ __ ] three times
that's true yeah um no are they nice
they are the biggest bathrooms i've ever
seen
there's four rooms before you get to
anything that has water in it
wow i mean well that's good i mean
there's
i'm sure the lines are non-existent yeah
oh there's i mean it's crazy it's just
anyway just when you started talking
about size of restrooms it really it
took me to another level
yeah brought you back yeah we gotta go
babe
y'all do no no i meant to the stadium oh
okay
i ain't leaving you got to kick my ass
out well we will in about 45 minutes
is that it look that's just one room
yeah
can you see any other rooms nick that is
pretty nice that's nice
that is cool it's not a lot okay
maybe they won't let you tape it or they
want to keep that secret yeah yeah
it but it is just it's really cool it's
really high-end
it's like a magic castle of toiletry
what
uh what is so what's kind of like do you
do you see yourself now like obviously
you know you got a lot of people
interested do you feel any new pressure
do you feel
do you feel anything like that or do you
feel pressure do you feel inspiration
like what do you kind of feel if
anything
um probably um
fear more than anything i don't feel
pressure
um uh it's just a little scary to me
and not in a bad way i'm not like you
know it's just i don't know how to
explain it like it's just um
it's weird you know what i mean like
it's weird
i never expected any of this um
you know fame scares me money scares me
i'm i'm pretty
happy and content so those things change
people or
can change people so i'm scared of that
it's just all kind of like i'm trying to
just
does that make sense do you how do you
feel about that
yeah yeah i mean it's scary to me it's
scary
yeah money's scary popularity is scary
um money's kind of scary because i feel
like i never had any money and i don't
and i just don't no i think i always
judged people with money as well and so
then when you start to make some money
you're like damn
those people were just you know i don't
want to be the same way that i felt like
those people were towards me maybe yeah
but also just realizing like those
people were just people
probably trying to do their best um
[Music]
yeah it's definitely kind of scary will
people look at you differently yeah
you know it's like especially coming
from i feel like some of the
environments maybe you and i are from
where
you know it always the people with money
were always kind of the bad guy i felt
like
yeah maybe that's just my perception no
i can definitely see that
rich people dude you went over to
somebody's house and they had
you know curtains you know and you're
like these [ __ ]
yeah yeah no as i was like to say it's
not even like
where we're from it's not even like rich
people it's like
people that lived in like a
three-bedroom two-bath brick house with
a trampoline in the backyard
was rich to me oh that was you had money
yeah okay if you have a minivan parked
out front
you have money dude if my this kid
brandon
broke his [ __ ] head open on a stack
of bricks that were next to their
trampoline and i was like you rich piece
of [ __ ]
because he had a stack of bricks and
yeah because he had cause that meant
they were building something
and you had money yeah i was just like
oh must be
tough dude splitting your head open on
some [ __ ] high-end textiles you piece
of [ __ ]
you know yeah i do so yeah i think i had
so much
judgment sometimes against that whole
universe
that it makes me feel just way
uncomfortable
you know i still live in the same
apartment i've been in for the past
seven seven years and so
i'm just afraid sometimes to spend any
money
yeah i get scared i get scared to give
nicker rays
no i feel the exact same way i honestly
do
greg drives a truck that has a half a
million miles on it he refuses to get a
new truck
although he just bought a brand new
[ __ ] 70 000
road runner but road runner what is that
oh like a mopar roadrunner like a 69
roadrunner
68 let's get a picture of that yeah this
sounds like
but he i mean he's all going to split in
the divorce yeah
um yeah same thing like we're afraid to
and you know i don't have a million
dollars in the bank but i'm making more
than i ever have
yeah that is beautiful and it's blue too
just like that
oh no that is nice dude yep that's it
that is something i'll freaking let you
hecky my butt
in that thing i thought you were talking
about that thing that brennan's shawb
used to drive that damn uh
looked like a big mosquito oh
yeah that's nice oh that's beautiful
yeah we just splurged
wow and is it run yet did you guys have
it running yeah it's a race car
damn so he doesn't drive it yeah it's
been sitting in our
driveway for eight months so what is it
about um
being down there and saying oh wait you
don't drive it at all yet no not that
that's that's it's not street legal okay
yeah so what will make it street legal
he won't he's gonna take it to the he's
gonna take it to the uh strip
start racing it hell yeah yeah and
that'd be great for some tammy videos
dude i would like to go sit him on one
of those yeah
i want to be there it'll be fun i want
to be just that
like uh i want to be medieval knievel
you know what i'm saying
i want to be on a dirt bike but with a
damn lamp oh
and with that mullet yeah oh yeah yeah
let the lord freaking work
yes yes um what is it you feel like
about being down there in san diego and
in that area
i really like it because it's still
california but it's not l.a
i don't know if i could live in l.a yeah
it's skeptical oh yeah yeah
um oh just the weather
i know that's stupid to say but like you
know texas was miserable
and you're hardly ever miserable in san
diego
the taco shops it's just i just love it
i don't think
it would take a lot to get us to move i
think if we were to move anywhere else
it would be
austin yeah austin area um
which you know we're going back to the
heat but i love the austin area um
but i'm i think we're going to be here
for the rest of our lives hopefully
san diego wow i just love it and do you
guys have offspring are y'all fertile or
anything like that no
we're fertile okay uh so that's a choice
yeah um
yeah no thanks no thanks for now maybe i
don't know
i keep saying oh in five years we've
been married oh my gosh
11 years yeah and i'll say oh let's wait
three or four years and come back and
see and every three or four years we're
like
no no and let's wait through you know so
and then now my career's kind of taken
off so i'm like i don't know
i won't be like if we don't have kids i
don't think
either of us are going to be like oh man
we missed we should have had
no i'll be good now which would you
freeze a batch of them eggs you think
no that freaking cause i think cold
easter you know
start that thing up for me i'm thinking
if it happens it was meant to be if it
doesn't it's not
so i'm not going to go out of my way you
know
i don't know yeah you know what i mean
like
i don't know i've never had so i've
never had like a strong
desire to have kids okay and i'll and
i've always said
i won't until that happens
you know i used to work with this old
lady and she asked me if i had kids and
i said no and she said
well let me tell you this don't have
kids just because you feel like you
should
have because it'll make it harder have
kids if you want kids
i was like that's that's so true and so
i've i've never
felt the strong need to get that back
yeah
but hell in five years i might i don't
know so i'm gonna wait until that
happens and if it never happens
all good i hate to interrupt the bonanza
but
sometimes you gotta get your brain
re-ignited
recalibrated really and something that
will help you
is a company called better help you know
i've suffered from mental health issues
mental disorder probably you know i wake
up in the morning and i don't want to do
it
and i don't even care what it is and
when i need help
sometimes i don't i don't you know
there's not a place i can go there's not
a therapist i can drive to or there's
not
you know somebody there's not somebody
in my area you know i might live in a
rural area
well that is all changing thanks to
better help
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own
licensed professional therapist
i mean you can access them on your phone
you can access them over facetime
you can access them over text there's a
broad range of expertise in betterhelp's
counselor network which nate which may
not be locally available in many areas
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
as with traditional therapy it's it's
time for a change in therapy it's time
that everyone should be able to get help
and this is how
visit betterhelp.com
[Music]
t-h-e-o that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over half a million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional that's right
a special offer for this past week and
listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o if you need help don't be afraid
don't be ashamed
and get it now back to the episode
it has been reported and i'm sadly to
share it with you
that americans are overpaying on car
insurance by over 21 billion dollars
what honk honk
hold up i got traffic in my brain
suddenly that's right americans are
overpaying
on car insurance by over 21 billion
dollars
but searching for a better deal for car
insurance it can take hours
and typically results in a barrage of
unwanted spam calls oh who's this
ah i don't i just i was on the website
and now this uh
until now things have changed thanks to
the zebra.com
thezebra.com is the nation's
leading car insurance comparison
site it's long overdue
and it's the only place you can compare
quotes side by side
from over 100 providers and choose the
best
for you in 90 seconds or less
plus they will never sell your
information to spammers
so you won't get the unwanted calls and
emails the harassment
tech crunch calls the zebra kayak
for auto insurance the best part is that
it's completely free
you can save up to 670 a year
using the zebra.com with states
reopening and people back
on the road the zebra is committed to
making sure you're covered at the lowest
price possible
don't go from one site to the next so it
takes too long
your time is too valuable save on car
and home insurance as well if you need
it go today and start saving at
the zebra.com slash t-h-e-o
you're gonna get car insurance support
the podcast
that's the zebra.com slash t-h-e-o
t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a dot com slash
theo thank you
do you do you get up like do you have
like a daily routine kind of you kind of
go by the wayside like
just whatever you know kind of i do have
a daily routine and
i have to or i won't do [ __ ]
i won't do [ __ ] if i don't have like my
week planned out
my yeah day-to-day so just i'm gonna
film this day i'm gonna post this day i
have you know
phone calls this day i have everything
and then my nieces live with us so now
i'm homeschooling them
no how old are they three days a week
eight and ten oh my god are they smart
yeah they are they start uh they start
this week
so um i'm doing that three days a week
no and you're given lessons and
everything yeah
what kind of stuff are they learning
about well it's a lot of like
just math and [ __ ] i'm going to teach
them i'm kind of going to go out of the
box i'm going to teach them how to cook
at a grocery shop stuff like that you
know what i mean because so many damn
adults
don't know how to cook like their mom my
sister who lives with us
holy [ __ ] can't even make spaghetti dude
really yeah
that's heartbreaking yeah and i you know
i cook and so i'm like y'all are gonna
learn how to cook
yeah even if they were boys i would
teach them how to cook oh it's such a
skill man
dude yeah even if we all you make every
night is macaroni and cheese you're
going to learn how to do it
you know we're split up an apple or
something exactly you know exactly
i remember we used to do like my mom
would
work and so we would make whatever you
know we had at the house
so we'd always come up with some real
bad ideas and [ __ ] and make it like more
uh we used to do macaroni with
marshmallows i think we went through a
little phase of that [ __ ] and it was
and you ate that yeah yeah we ate it
well here's the thing once you made it
you gotta eat yeah oh yeah yeah you
can't throw it away no there wasn't a
lot of wiggle room
but the thing is did you make it a
second time and a third well here's what
happened somebody would make it one of
the kids would make it we had four
children one of them would make it
then the other three would try to up out
do them you know with their [ __ ]
idea
and my one of my sisters at the time was
five so she would just [ __ ] burn all
kinds of [ __ ]
and then we would fight you know yeah oh
you got to throw in a fight there
oh yeah you can't not fight but i really
enjoyed that yeah
um when you see so you have a lot of
interaction with like a lot of different
celebrities and stuff it seems like that
have reached out to you
um is all that been organic i know you
had the
uh the uh the fan attack video with uh
luke bryan with luke bryan that was
really really crazy and his mother
was one of the best moments ever
did so i have never ever
reached out to a celebrity that's all
been them coming to me
and winona judd follows me that's why i
throw that out there
yep so anyway um yeah
so a little back story on this so they
contact me
luke and his wife they call me like
because i supposed to go to this charity
event they call me like a week before
he's like hey i want to try to prank my
mom like
i'm thinking about if you attack me and
i'm like yeah that's that's great that's
hilarious let's do it
he reached out yeah out of the blue yeah
so he messaged you as if his somebody
who works with a message
his wife had his uh his wife follows me
on instagram okay
so we follow each other and they caught
yeah they invited me to their charity
event and then
him and his wife facetimed me like a
week before i was supposed to go out
there he's like i have this idea
damn it's romantic yeah um
so i get there and i'm thinking it's
just gonna be just a simple oh yeah
he goes so security's out front and i've
been telling my mom
my mom all morning that there's a crazy
fan out there
and that she's threatening to kill us
and i go
hold on so this is like is she gonna
make sure she doesn't have a gun
yeah like because i didn't know he was
gonna like tell her that i was
threatening to kill that so his mom was
scared right she's on alert before yeah
yeah because this is her son this is the
dang meal ticket
yeah yeah yeah i'm saying kill my other
son yeah kill randy brian
you know what i'm saying y'all could
damn yeah
set a bear trap on the third hole for
randy but we need luke you know
but i thought she was set up to to be
scared of me okay so i'm like oh my god
are you sure
he's like no it's going to be great i
was like make sure because you know
she's from the south
i don't know if she's you know make sure
she's not packing he goes we've we've
made sure
so apparently she does i don't know yeah
he goes we've made sure i said okay
and that's something nice about an older
person you could free like it's it
you can feel easy if they got a gun on
yeah because there's not as much
body there's not as much body on them
yeah and she was super skinny too so you
can you know yeah
quickly you can give her a big hug and
double over like that the next thing you
know you've done a full body search
um but we did the prank and i thought
she was gonna i mean i felt
i instantly thought i shouldn't have
done this yeah i shouldn't have done
this at what point let's go through a
little bit of it
um okay and is it is it hot in here
isn't it a little bit i'm feeling a
little better you are okay yeah
i put it down to 70. you did it yeah you
have a little sweat right here
thank you thank you thank you yeah yeah
you look very nice
thank you okay so you sneak in uh
rolling on top she throws her cigarette
hey i got her i got her i got her i got
her i got her i got her
hey you know it wasn't until i got up
as soon as i stand up i'm like oh my god
give me five minutes
oh and there's mom holding her back yeah
come on
right there i go oh no
i thought she's going to pass out
and look at that wow it all comes to a
head right there mom
saves the day oh yeah shows that she's
still got that mother wolf
in her you know oh yeah afterwards she
was like i was gonna whoop your ass
and she was gonna too she was dressed
she was yesterday did you see her throw
the sticks she had she go
through it she was ready she throw that
[ __ ] like she was warming up oh my
god like she was swollen ryan dude like
she was about to pitch some [ __ ]
haters
right into your face that was fun that
was fun that's awesome
yeah um so do you feel like that world
kind of embraces you the
the like kind of the country music world
do you feel because
i feel like every you're just so i feel
like you're for everybody do you feel
like it's specific
no i feel like i'm for everybody um i
have a
from everywhere from all i mean every
ethnicity
i think people assume that only you know
white southern people um follow me and
no no no no that's not true i feel like
i'm for everybody
because everybody loves redneck humor
you don't have to be a redneck to
enjoy that you know it's [ __ ] funny
well a lot of it's just relatable stuff
like even if you're looking at your
youtubes and it's going through the
drive through
and just you know um you know the
people snacking on different stuff and
experiencing it and just
uh to be in that moment also going
through the drive-thru with somebody a
lot of times yeah you get to call
you're behind a couple cars dude this
[ __ ] gets you
it's some damn intimacy because you're
just chilling there that's the biggest
commitment i've ever made sometimes is
being three cars deep in a drive-through
with somebody i don't know very well
sitting there waiting
together god you know those
drive-through videos are my most popular
and most requested videos
which blows my mind yeah because i'm
just sitting there
eating dude yeah have you watched it
have you seen the mukbangs on
on youtube i've seen some of them i like
the donut one that you and jim did when
y'all stacked those different types of
meals
so here's how that started like a couple
years ago
mukbang it's called mukbang or something
i don't say that word
because it's stupid it's a muck bank
right okay um
they started getting like people were
getting millions and millions of views
and making money and i'm like
and i said this is the dumbest thing
i've ever seen you sat there and watched
someone eat i thought it was ridiculous
i go let me do one as tammy to basically
make fun of it
and so i only planned on doing one so i
did one it's my
most viewed on youtube people would not
let me not do another one
and it's it's my mo if i go a week or
two without doing one
my dms are like when's the next month
i'm like you just it's it's so funny
it's so easy
it's easy content i just go through the
drive through yeah it's all improv
i talk about whatever i make [ __ ] up and
eat yeah and that's it
it's beautiful man you gave me that
poster i love that
um i also love it's just like
i think it just feels
it obviously like it's produced your
[ __ ] you know it's like you guys are
doing it but it just feels
i don't know it just feels fun i'm
trying to think of what really makes me
get into it you know i'm trying to think
of what makes me because it's ridiculous
it's almost
it's almost like watching a car wreck i
think it's no because for me
sorry like for me it is
because i just have been in that
situation so many times and never
like just been in a moment like that and
you're like yeah this is actually
kind of close to what [ __ ] is like when
you're just kind of with somebody
yeah you know and you have to decide on
food and you display your best chance to
display your manners on a damn
date sometimes is it the you know when
the drive-thru lady says what can i get
you
you know and you get to see if the
person's nice or not if they say yeah
thank you yeah um yeah so i think some
of that just seeing it just feels real
human
yeah relatable yeah i feel real
relatable people love them
so i keep doing them do you think about
doing
like uh something that's more in the
acting world i know you've had some
stuff go on but do you think about that
kind of are you kind of happy with the
space that you're in i
i'm happy with the space i'm in um
but and if i don't go beyond that i'll
be so
happy and content but yeah i'm i'm
trying to write a tammy movie right now
so we'll see if that ever gets made or
happy you know
you know how [ __ ] goes like you know but
i'm trying to write a tanya movie
um got some stuff kind of going on the
work so hopefully
that'd be great but if it doesn't i'm
good you know what i mean
yeah but i'm just taking it a day at a
time and i'm you know opportunities i'm
like let's let's try it let's do it
yeah yeah it's great yeah
i i would i'm trying to think if i
have a opportunity in something i'm
doing i would i would certainly include
you
you know thank you yeah i think it would
just be fun
that'd be great what kind of thing could
we what kind of even thing what kind of
characters could we be you think and i'm
not playing tammy
you can do whatever you if we if i make
a team you just be alive
if i if i make a tiny movie you got to
make a cameo in the tammy movie
oh i'm not doing uh oh a cameo yeah i'm
just not paying somebody
i'm not doing a damn birthday party for
somebody for nine dollars
no no you just gotta be you just gotta
be in the movie oh i'm stopping that
[ __ ] man
yeah you know but i want a real role i
wanna be a damn
you know somebody that runs and works at
a gift shop or somebody that
you know somebody that fixes something i
want to be somebody that knocks on a
door and shows up yeah
you want to play an important part and
you should yeah i'll do it dude
yes god that's what i want yes
well it's a great time and we're happy
and on the website if you go to
theovonne.com
it's been refurbished and rehashed
reimagined and
creative eyes and who's helped us
well they're called modify
modify is a web design
and development group that offers game
changing
service providing subscription-based
professional web design for the cost of
your old cable bill
why would you want to do it yourself or
pay top dollar
for less value modify
will design your site its unbeatable
plan
is fast affordable and high quality with
20 years in the website design game
modify's last website ever plan
is the best option out there heck we
just got it
i mean we just got it for just 249
a month you will enjoy the relief of an
easy process quick turnaround
and an evergreen website and the
convenience of having a personal
web design team assigned to your account
to handle all your ongoing website needs
that's right they
build your site they put it together
and they service it it's 249 a month
modify's plan includes unlimited updates
unlimited support
easy editing tools and future
redesigns no cost to build no contract
and they do it all for you only 249 a
month
i'm using them check out our site
theovonn.com
get yours today with a 249 dollar a
month at
modify.com theo
that's m-o-d-i-p-h-y dot
c o m t h e o
that's modify with a p h
m o d i p h y dot com slash t h e o
these guys don't f around gang
what else is going on um
not much dude i freaking left some stuff
out on the counter at home
what'd you leave out hmm i left some
blueberries and i left a damn london
broil
the blueberries will be okay what's a
london broil it's a meat it's like a
kind of a high-end kind of meat i guess
a medium end
and it's raw yeah oh it's that may be
done for just cause the heat and the no
air
yeah oh you're gonna take a loss on that
one yeah it just hurts a little yeah
at least you got the blueberries london
broil i've never heard of that
it's good man it's the best thing
brittany ever did for us it looks like a
skirt steak
uh some no yeah
you know it's a little more i feel like
it's a little more
bold like there's not a lot of taste to
it it looks kind of great but there's
not a lot of taste to it kind of like
it's very brit it's as british as you
could get wait but it says grilled steak
served cut diagonally so it's just the
cut
oh really so it's just a regular steak
it's just how it's cut right but they
cut it out of a place that definitely
is english as [ __ ] i feel like it like
when i'm eating it as compared to like a
brisket or something
it doesn't stand out okay no no that
makes sense that makes sense because if
you're eating a brisket you're not
thinking about
paris france no you're thinking about
texas
okay that okay makes sense if i'm having
a brisket i'm thinking about wherever i
am at that moment
um what was that what's in the news nick
we'll get into a couple of news topics
what have we got
ex-navy seal uh credited with killing
osama bin laden he was
uh people got angry with him on twitter
because he was bragging about not
wearing a mask he took a selfie
with a uh a marine behind him or a guy
in a marine cap who had a mascot and he
goes i'm not a [ __ ] like this guy
and people
and then risky to tweet about it yeah
that's brave to tweet about it i almost
wonder if he was tweeting out of
like trying to get back at the guy uh i
think it's the rivalry between seals and
marines
oh i could see a little bit of that yeah
okay okay well this goes really and
recently i had i i saw a dang man in the
um
in a marine's hat and i thought it said
mariners on it seattle mariners
and so i'm asking him about ichiro and
you know all of these different guys and
ken griffey jr and all this [ __ ] and the
guy is looking at him like i
am a damn and it said marines and not
mariners
he looks at me like i'm a damn still in
school adult you know
it was it was the most awkward thing
ever
um but dude i think if you kill bin
laden dude i don't think you got to wear
it i don't think you have to wear a mask
i don't think that dude needs to wear a
damn
shirt if he doesn't want it yeah i don't
care if he wears damn two dicks to a
urinal
this dude killed osama bin laden oh
that's him
that's him oh i see okay okay and also
this guy seems semi ginger you know how
hard it is for a ginger to sneak
through the dam through you know where
it get i mean it gets pretty
you know it's more of a tan environment
over there in the desert oh yeah
everybody's got a tan oh yeah so you're
just gonna lollygag through with a damn
you know with that damn torch skin
torch skin i mean i just don't know if
this guy needs
i mean he should wear a shirt that said
hey i'm not wearing a mask because i
killed osama bin laden
yeah oh i think but for me i feel like
he gets out of jail free
yeah and i don't i mean
i wear a mask just to i guess respect
other people but
oh totally if someone comes if i'm in
the grocery and someone's not i'm not i
don't say anything or freak out
no no i'm not a man yeah i'm not some
kind of mask warrior no no
yeah we're not the mask police no i'm
not the mass police i'm not even a man
i don't want to be i'm not even a damn
masked parole officer
you know yeah like i have certain
feelings about the whole
uh pandemic and everything but i wear a
mask it's like somebody
it's like shaking somebody's hand when
you meet them and if you feel
comfortable after that
if people choose not to then that's
between them yeah i think it's between
consenting adults almost kind of
agree um but i think it's for me
this guy killed bin laden i think this
dude doesn't have to wear damn shoes and
a freaking 7-eleven if he doesn't want
to you know i'm saying i think he can go
high on the hog as he wants
i agree nick what do you think yeah uh
yeah i i i agree he should be able to do
whatever he wants
not wear the mask i'm really worried
about this though uber and lyft might
shut down
in uh california on friday because uh
they're trying to make
all the drivers be employees instead of
independent contractors so they're just
gonna withdraw
they're threatening to just withdraw
from california and just shut down and
there won't be uber and lyft in
california
on friday i wonder why just in
uh because it's california state that is
trying to
protect the employees or independent
contractors and make employees but
if they shut down then it's hurting
everybody wow and that's the only place
i
nick frequents right yeah yeah yeah he
had a car and then he
well it's your story nick i don't want
to throw you under your own car uh
tree a tree fell on it uh during a
windstorm it was like uh
first nice car i ever bought and a tree
fell on it and
totaled it and then the only wind storm
and the only tree in los angeles too
i was gonna ask was that here in l.a
like
what it was the night of the super bowl
they actually said 2
000 trees were cleared from los angeles
that night there was
oh yeah i slept right through it wow
what's what's taking so long with
insurance uh nothing i i got
paid i got paid out for yeah i got paid
for it and then the pandemic happens oh
okay yeah yeah but then
i don't know ubering's actually i like
it
yeah it's so convenient like it that
sucks
i like it but i just sometimes i get
damn judgmental when i'm in there and i
just
i will in my head i'll have like a stack
of dimes that i'm giving as a tip you
know hypothetical dimes
and each time they do something a little
that doesn't really meet my
fancy i guess like what i will okay
smacking their gum okay yeah
a lady gave me a rod from here to home
and smacked her gum
so much that i had to go see my
therapist that week and that is 100
true and that still i can still hear her
smacking
and it was just irrational how much she
did it yeah and
um another thing uh
talking to me about a lot of different
stuff no you're right
you're right i don't want to talk at all
yeah i'd like and if they talk
but i'll make it yeah no you're right on
that one and it's hard to curtail that
conversation you know
yeah yeah do you ever do you ever have
people
ask you that don't know who you are oh
what do you do
yes do you hate it or do you like it
because i hate it
i i hate it now
okay i think there was a time when i
liked it what do you tell them
i say i work in i work in entertainment
you know
i do uh we do outreach i've said i'll do
animal outreach i have some basic kind
of lies i'll tell
you know i work for the city you know
you know or i'll do unemployment i'll do
you know i'll say that a lot of times or
i'll
uh if it's somebody that i feel like is
if it's somebody that's not gonna talk
much that's how i gauge what answer i
get
same if i can feel that they're gonna
because
when you say comedian or you say
youtuber or whatever you say
if i if if i know that they're gonna be
like oh let me put you know what i mean
i'll make something up yeah um but if
it's someone that
i usually say like social media
marketing which i don't even know what
that is
yeah but i tell people that i like and
they're always like oh like what i'm
like just like
facebook and instagram i just make
something up
but i hate it when people ask me what i
do and i don't know why
i think it's because they do like once
you tell them they like
want to look you up you know what i mean
they make a big you know
so one guy's playing me a thing of mine
one time while he's driving i'm like
this is insane you know
so that really you know that's
unfortunate do you have this instance
where if you are with somebody
um and they don't it's kind of
uncomfortable sometimes if people are
giving you attention and they're not
giving it to
somebody else that you're with which
they wouldn't probably because they
don't know that person or they're not a
fan of them
i always feel so uncomfortable because
i'm like man i don't want my friend to
not feel good or not feel like
or feel like i'm more important than
them you know like when you get
recognized
yeah that makes me feel yeah if i'm with
like my you know family like my sisters
or like my close close friends that are
like used to it i'm fine
but if i'm with someone that's like you
know never
like for instance i was in nashville
before the pandemic and i was
visiting some um college friends we went
out and i had people recognize me and it
it
it's awkward when they're just kind of
standing there like you know
and you you know what i'm saying like
it's it's it can be very awkward you're
right like when
they're not giving anybody else
attention and they're kind of making a
big deal about you but
yeah you feel some type of way a little
bit you start to develop this sixth
sense though i know when i walk in the
room i can tell like who knows who
doesn't
how this is all gonna play out like you
start to get and it's not an ego thing
it's just
it's like you've done you've been
through this little drill so many times
you start to just
you develop a sixth sense you develop
you develop okay
this person know i can feel them they're
telling this person
this guy's not going to say anything but
he i feel like he knows
um i wish this [ __ ] knew you know
yeah because i always get some real
mukbangs that know
a lot of yeah men are always hollering
at me really
god yes
it's crazy like guys wanting to go on a
damn walk or something
go on a walk just go away just you need
to get some fresh air
yeah but unless one of us is a murderer
you know
what else we got in the news nick see
what else
do you really keep up with the news like
you know not a ton i stay off these days
it's
yeah i don't trust it that much anymore
yeah
it wants me to not have fun yeah
exactly i'm kind of the same way
one thing that gets me though i feel
like we need a damn centralized
mask like i mean people are wearing
yeah you know somebody cut out part of a
hat and taped it over their face you
know
you got another guy some guy shows up
and you think he's a surgeon and he
[ __ ] works at
best buy you know what i'm saying
there's so many you have a guy in a damn
uh scream three mask like there's like
how there's no protocol for
unleash a mask that everyone needs yeah
did you see that viral meme going around
just a few days ago there's a guy with a
long beard
he had it tucked up up and under his
sunglasses and he was using his beard as
a mask
now that's pretty cool i would do that
that was pretty cool
yeah this one guy had his hand amputated
and he saved it
and he got it put in front of his and it
hung it on two damn little door hooks
it's just beautiful to see a lot of
stuff that's going on um
i saw it on instagram
but it's like you put a centralized mask
out you got people
just goddamn half a panty in front of
their head you know what i'm saying
and are they serious i don't know they
can't be you can't be oh my
but it qualifies that's the thing that's
funny it's like oh as long as you walk
in
you know as long as you have something
yeah
right there it could be [ __ ] anything
you're good come on in yeah that's
what's so crazy
to me i'm not a doctor [ __ ] i'm not even
an exterminator
but i'll tell you this dude
just anything in front of your mouth
that that's not a real
that's not a plan it doesn't even have
to be clocked yeah it doesn't
as long as it's connected behind your
ears [ __ ] anything dude
oh dude that one guy had a strong enough
overbite and they're like that qualifies
you'll have a fella just just uh comb
his bangs
straight down across his face oh bang
face yeah he's healthy
get him in here and then you got some 60
year old man in a damn raggedy andy mask
over there [ __ ] drinking purell out
there it's just
it's like how is it there's no protocol
no no i've never thought about that
until you brought it up that you're
right
like gosh nick bring up the anti-masters
league
um if you can uh i didn't know about
this
well this is something let's take us
here nick what is this
do you want the anti-mass league we'll
go right here uh marijuana
vending machines are now available in
colorado with uh colorado with
more to follow uh yeah
and do you guys uh do marijuana in that
um
i feel like i i was like 28 the first
time i ever smoked weed
oh yeah um i used to on occasion and it
started giving me panic attacks
where were you at when you smoked it
first were you with your man or what
oh my gosh i think yeah we we live in
san diego
i moved san diego when i was 26 so yeah
yeah um
at the house and who introduced you to
it was it you was it him was it
i've always been around people that
smoke so i think we had a roommate i
can't
i don't even know man um but smoked it
loved it
laughed my ass it was one of those great
laughing you know so i do it like once
or twice a month
great had a great time for maybe two
three years and then boom
panic attacks no matter what so i smoke
cbd now because i still like the smell
so i'm just a cbd here okay and does it
feel like it calms you a little yeah
oh yeah it works and i don't feel like
somebody's going to murder me yeah yeah
honest to god i remember the worst the
worst time i ever got paranoid during it
um smoked weed i went to bed
and i was positive that greg was going
to kill me like oh i hate that no
like i thought he's going to murder me
tonight it was so real
and he came in that he came in the
bedroom oh which is the first sign that
somebody's gonna murder you they come
into the room
in a dark room he comes in i'm like oh
my god
how's he gonna do it does he have a gun
is he gonna strangle me yeah what's he
gonna do
and he walks over my side of the batman
and i'm literally my heart i'm literally
like oh god
oh god i'm gonna i'm gonna die i mean
and this was real dude yeah in your head
yeah
it's real and he leans over and goes
goodnight baby and gives me a kiss and i
go
he's [ __ ] faking it he's gonna wait
till i fall asleep
and he's gonna do it and i did not sleep
that night
into the morning and i woke up i was
like i need to
not smoke weed anymore yeah and i
yeah i don't smoke anymore isn't that
crazy yeah but
also some of his behaviors
you know yeah some of that [ __ ] is a
dead giveaway dude when you're high
you're like oh this motherfucker's gonna
kill me
and then next thing you know they go and
uh take a sip of water and you're like
oh yeah
yep just hydrating up this damn murderer
you know
i feel you bro we don't do that yeah um
what about do you ever i feel like
i remember one time getting so high and
going to a damn funeral
and i thought i just
oh and i was laughing it gave me the
damn giggles dude
and it was just like can you believe
everybody's tripping out dude
just because mr polito is dead dude
nobody even liked this guy people were
just there
i'm like half these people are
pretending i'm [ __ ] laughing
and then i'm starting to think yeah i
started getting paranoid and thinking
that people somebody was a murderer
because it looks like a damn crime scene
where you're at a funeral
yeah a movie scene yeah somebody yeah
it's like a whodunit
yeah i can see that when you're high at
a funeral it is a straight up who
doesn't do you think it would be a good
experience uh there was just weed going
through the area okay and you happen to
and i happen to have a funeral in the
docket
but it was uh yeah i would never do it
again man
that's the crazy thing about weed dude
it's just
it can be either [ __ ] amazing
and the best or can
bring so much [ __ ] fear like oh my
gosh it's one or the other and i don't
get it
yeah it's like back page for your dna
it's like meeting somebody off the
internet
that's what weed is man yeah you never
know what you're gonna get
yeah you might get murdered you might
get not murdered yeah
you know it's one or the other yeah um
this was something that happened this is
in uh take us through a little bit of
this nick
the anti-mass league of san francisco
was an organization
formed to protest the requirement for
people in san francisco to wear masks
during the 1918
pandemic yes so they had a mat yeah they
had a group of people and actually
there's a new york times article if you
if you
try and look that up real quick um so
basically they had something very much
like what we have now
where people didn't want a lot of people
didn't want to wear masks a lot of
people did want to wear masks
there was people getting ill um and
there's people on the street the police
would even give you
fines like if you didn't have a mask on
you could get a fine for like five
dollars up to 25
that was a lot back then oh yeah it was
a it was a just damn
damn half of a butt load dude if you're
doing a damn gender reveal and
it's your friend paige it was half a
damn bl
the first infection go down a little bit
there they are
was identified in march at uh army base
in kansas
by the fall of 1918 seven cities had put
in effect mandatory face mask
laws and um
[Music]
the masked city san francisco became
known as the mast
city because of this pandemic damn
and people didn't know how to wear them
oh and somebody yeah somebody shot
somebody eventually
because they weren't wearing a mask yep
on october 28 a blacksmith named
james whisser stood on powell and market
streets
using a crowd to urging a crowd to
dispose of their masks
um and somebody hit him with a sack of
silver
damn that'll get you yeah
shitty way to go you always want to make
money and then bam son
that [ __ ] gets you right in the chat no
um
but anyway yeah i mean this somebody
died nobody's killed anybody yet for not
wearing a mask or wearing one i don't
think
uh i don't think so so we're still in
good space there
yeah you know compared to how it had
been i mean people really were losing it
wow
um do we have any other questions that
came in nick uh that was pretty much it
for the questions okay all right
well damn cool um
what are y'all gonna do what do you feel
about this coming up like the holidays
in halloween have you started thinking
about that at all well
every year we have a big halloween party
you do
oh yeah and um and there's
nobody there that i know it's all like
because i don't really know anybody in
san diego i really don't like all my
friends are up here in l.a and stuff
um so it's like my friend it's like my
sister's like
employed like work employee like work uh
what do you call them
co-workers did you get a bank or
something no
no she works they work at a plumbing
like a plumbing office oh yeah whatever
so it's just plumbers
um but anyway there's always like a ton
of peop like
it's one of those things where people
invite people to where i don't know
who's there
but anyway it's always a big fun time we
look forward to it every year we'll
start decorating like a month before
and we're probably not gonna have it
this year yeah but we'll still have fun
you know what i mean um but it seems
like such a time when mass
you need masks it's almost
you know everybody has a mask on it's
the one party you can have
i didn't think about that you're right
kind of i mean i'm not calling you out
for not having it yeah i just want you
to damn have it
yeah i know you know even though i stay
home all the time i [ __ ] love knowing
yeah that somebody's having a halloween
party that people are having a good time
yeah that's true that's true i think we
were going to try to still have
something but not just
just invite like us and the immediate
friends not
not all the people but we'll still have
something but yeah that kind of sucks
but
and you also get the judgment from
social media
if you know if i were to have that big
halloween party
oh gosh yeah you know you got the people
on your ass but
i think we're just gonna have something
small and then we're going home for
thanksgiving which is the first time in
like
eight years we've gone home back to
thackerville or no
yeah well durant which is close so
spectacular um but yeah
so we're doing that um my sister's 30th
is after thanksgiving so we're renting a
cabin in oklahoma oh
fun i love oklahoma yeah well certain
parts
we went to tulsa we went to the ball
ball room or something yeah
man it was i like it up there it was a
great show yeah
i like it up there when you do your live
show what is it
like what do you do actually um so what
i did
before the pandemic was i would come out
as me
and do like like 10 minutes or so and
um i would thank everybody for coming
and they think that was it
and it got so awkward that people were
pissed they'd be like
i'll be walking to the crowd and they're
like like i paid you know
like pissed and then i would come back
out as tammy yeah
and that's when it really really took
off oh yeah
i'm thinking though for the future shows
like i'm just gonna do tammy
and i almost only did the chelsea stuff
just to see if i could do it as me and i
can
but it's more comfortable doing it as
tammy is it oh yeah
oh yeah it's more comfortable i feel
like the material is funnier
although everything i i say
is true and happened to me but i tell it
as tammy oh yeah yeah and what about
that little
little gem that little sugar calamari
why don't you bring him out
oh god he lives god i would love to see
him at something well he's
uh busy he works at he's an assistant
manager of the dollar general
no he isn't in what city oh gosh where's
he i know he's in georgia
some old town outside of macon gosh i
can't remember it but uh
i love dollar general oh yeah he's he's
he's running the place
well a lot of people don't realize
dollar general if you live in a small
area rural area
dollar general is it it will be like the
walmart
yeah for three towns or four towns you
go to wherever the cl
the dollar general will be the quote the
place that everybody goes kind of for
everything yeah
people realize that god that [ __ ]
pisses me off dude
dollar general is like popping in in
small
towns yeah they know what they're doing
yeah they're making money and they're
good yeah
look at dollar general stock pull it up
nick oh and i know it probably hadn't
done well in this during this pandemic
but prior to that
i feel like that that's this is a hot
time for really well no i guess if
they're shut down
well if they're still open let me see
them over the past two years let me look
at
yeah give me a two year five year nick
they're open there's one year
see i mean that's a money maker yeah
they're making money dear god look at
that nothing but rising
where else can you judge your [ __ ]
neighbors
and get a damn broom yeah
and some and some dollar general uh hot
pockets
yeah not the hot pocket brand no dollar
and it feels like military-esque since
it has general in it you know i think a
lot of men don't mind going
yeah it's got that kind of vibe
yeah i just had a vision that one day
dolly parton comes on and you come on
and guest host that episode
because i'm going to be getting a studio
in nashville starting on september 1st
really
if you do that can you let me know i'm
letting you know oh if she's going to do
it yes yeah that's going to be a goal
i'm gonna set
or if you're doing it and i can come and
walk dude that doesn't matter it doesn't
matter and i see her doing this
i really do let's put it out to the
universe now make this happen
are you moving in asheville um i'm
getting a place there
okay so i'm gonna be there a lot but
i'm also we're not we're keeping this
and we're keeping
you know everything keeping my place
here and stuff so
i'm just kind of testing it out yeah but
yeah maybe that'd be fun maybe we will
come maybe we do some a couple of
episodes morgan wallin's going to come
on one
which i'm so excited about even though i
didn't ask him yet
he'll do it uh but i think he will do it
yeah
um that is awesome yeah i'm just kind of
excited just to be able to like i think
just have different types of people yeah
but i would but it's so funny because i
was
listening to dolly parton sings that i
will always love you
a lot of people don't know she did that
oh yeah people think it's whitney
houston she did was great but
no she you know what she wrote that she
wrote that after she
she quit that show that she was on no
way really
oh it's a haul for porter wagner she
wrote it for porter wagner who is her
boss
she was on that show with him and she
quit and he got pissed
because um she she made the show
shane porter she's what's that song
somebody's
were you wayne woman enough to take my
man no it's like
you ain't so and so and you ain't porter
i think it was her oh yeah yeah i know
what you're talking about yeah yeah
that's a newer song
oh it is i think so wayne johnny or
something like that yeah
yeah that's a newer song i don't know
who sings that um
um oh yeah oh you ain't dolly
[Applause]
yeah i was listening to her the other
day man i like her me too
her voice her voice is different than
anything else i've ever heard she's got
like a
yeah almost like a dolly voice i could
see that like dolly's voice is like you
know dolly's singing odd
it's like father time just damn busting
in your ear
you know she's singing it feels good i
just love her
but i will always love you put this on a
little bit nick we'll listen to a few
seconds and then we'll get out of here
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah my god
you could give me a reach around he
wouldn't get jealous okay yeah
[Music]
this is a bucket list i never knew i had
this
yeah yes
[Music]
what a moment
you know what i'm pretty confident i
wish i looked like 1970s
oh i think you got a lot of dolly thank
you
i think you just remind everybody you
know that
you know that just you just i don't know
you're just so confident
i wish i was as confident as you
sometimes thank you
you should be i know i don't know what
happened no
you you you are it's in there you should
be you got that mullet you got
majestic as [ __ ] i got a penis shaped
like a damn candy corn though oh wow
yeah hey that's different you know
you're different
you're right you're right you're right
it's amazing yeah it just feels weird or
something like that
yeah nobody wants to you know you don't
you know somebody orders a jug of milk
and you break out milk but it's in a
damn
you know it's in a cornucopia shape if
you don't want to drink it you know well
you just gotta find people that
you just gotta find a chick that's gonna
not be scared of that yeah
yeah and they're out there yeah i've
been dating too many shallow wings yeah
that don't like that candy corn
yeah you know find you a candy corn
lover yeah that's what i'm gonna do
come to our halloween party i will have
a big o it'll be on
zoom yeah as long as your husband brings
that damn haircut and i've been looking
at him in the distance guys i don't
maybe you guys i don't even know if he
said that he was in here
but and he has an announcement to make
actually as well right now oh i do
i'm oh god
don't give him a mic holy crap we're
having dinner with theo tonight
oh are we really or no yes we are he's
gonna actually be laying on the table
we're gonna eat sushi off of him
we're gonna actually get to have dinner
and dessert that's great
some candy corn for dessert exactly
oh i'm laying on my stomach for the
first course and on my back for the
second baby
yes sir but you guys have a new studio
that you guys are going to put together
right you want to talk about that or no
yeah we're working on it uh it should be
finished uh
first week of september it's in our home
our house was built in the 70s and the
the room is underneath the staircase but
it's a big room
and it was not finished when we moved in
like it was like a safe room
you know back in the day people had like
safe rooms so the walls weren't finished
when we bought the house we found an old
phone in there from the 70s
we found old porn magazines in the walls
yeah
so um i haven't seen the room yet it's
for my podcast that i'll be starting
greg hasn't let me see in the room but
he's been working on it for months so
it's gonna be
real nice yeah oh huh yeah
you can tell he's excited about it too
it's cool right when he came in i could
just see he was so excited
yeah and it just it hit me it just made
me feel excited
yeah he's sweet bless his heart he seems
he's very sweet
he seems just damn decent it's as good
as you can get these days for a man
we'll have to have you out there for our
podcast dude i would love to come down
that would be really cool we'll take you
to some dinner too
okay make you a brisket okay dude i'll
do it all
yeah we'll do it all i would love to
come down um and
and i'm going to put it out in the world
i want to get dolly and and we'll have
you come to nashville and we'll do
a just a dang episode let's do it
it's got to happen right it has to it's
going to happen it's going to happen it
will happen
it could happen it was used to be a
little boost it was the goal and
announced solid part
i wonder if she'll need a pound of weed
yeah we had we had we had a surplus busy
um and you know the podcast starts when
you said you don't know yet i don't know
yet
we're you know no rush on it hopefully
in the next couple months
i love it yeah if you haven't seen
chelsea which i don't know how you
haven't because she's all over
everything now um you got to check her
out uh
and we'll share all of her socials and
everything and just thanks so much over
the years you've just been so
encouraging even at times you've just
said something nice or
just mentioned me on instagram or
anything um i just appreciate it thank
you well you know i'm a huge [ __ ] fan
of yours so thank you for having me
well same because oh my god thank you
now i'm just floating
on the breeze and i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i
found i can feel it in my
bones but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on my heart shine
that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
[Music]
built